we can't wait for the new season of the
100 what will life after earth mean for
our favourite characters and what will
it mean for our ships check out the 10
couples we totally ship from the CW's
hit show Octavia and Lincoln link Tavia
fans we've got you covered
Octavia Blake is one fierce woman even
though she has a bad temper she is one
of our favorite characters Octavia is
brilliant she is great at surviving in
fact she was one of the first group
members to start speaking the language
of the grounders it's a lot easier to
get along with other people if you speak
the same language she also United all
the clans but she can be pretty ruthless
and there was a coop thankfully she had
a change of heart in season 5 she's not
all bad
Lincoln is such a great guy but the
tough world he grew up in kept trying to
make him a monster
his father forced him to end a man's
life when he was just a boy he was also
forced to become a reaper at one point
he's quiet but he is not afraid to
question things he has a strict moral
code that he stands up for Lincoln saved
Octavia from her crash and tended her
wounds later he risked his own life
several times to save her he was such a
good balance to her impulsiveness and
she helped him overcome his addiction to
the reaper drug we were devastated when
Lincoln sacrificed himself you'll always
be in our hearts
Linc Tavia Monti and Jasper okay okay we
know that Monti and Harper are a great
couple they might even be our OTP but
hear us out
Monti and Jasper would have made an
amazing couple these two best friends
have the ultimate bromance it wouldn't
take much to turn it into a romance
Monti and Jasper were imprisoned at the
same time and all they did was steal
some herbs life on the ark was awful
they were the perfect balance for each
other Monti was smart like really smart
he was fiercely loyal and he was also
way more reserved than Jasper Jasper
sort of becomes the center of attention
in the first season and he falls in love
with Maya
Jasper was bright and adventurous let's
not forget how Monty watched over Jasper
when he was sick they always made up
when they had fights Jasper had a hard
time recovering from Maya's death
in fact he ended his own life in season
4 but we think he would have been way
happier with Monty Monty had great
survival skills they could have lasted a
lot longer than Maya and Jasper
we're glad Monty got a pretty happy
ending but don't you think he would have
been happier with Jasper Clarke and LexA
Oh Alexa this ship seems like a match
made in well not heaven
more like post-apocalyptic earth these
two women were definitely a power couple
they were both respected and feared
leaders of their people and when Clarke
came to make an alliance with LexA the
calexis ship was born they had instant
chemistry Clarke is extremely loyal and
has a strong set of morals in fact these
traits have often caused her to make bad
decisions she eventually becomes known
as the commander of death LexA doesn't
act as ruthless as Clarke she's a lot
more fair and logical but she is very
loyal to her people too at first
Clarke wasn't ready for a relationship
we were devastated
we just wanted these two to end up
together but life on Earth was hard and
it wasn't meant to be
Lex's death was heart-wrenching if these
two have been able to stay together
things would have turned out differently
they would be unstoppable we can't wait
to see what is next for Clarke she's had
a lot of loss Bellamy and Clark Clark
gets shipped with a lot of people both
in Cannon and outside of it
she definitely has had a handful of
relationships on the show maybe it's
just because she is such an awesome
character one ship that we wish would
happen is Belle arc
who doesn't love a good enemies to
friends lovers story they have the
enemies to friends part down Bellamy and
Clarke have a lot in common
they are both protective of their loved
ones and they both have a softer side
that comes out every now and then at
first they didn't get along at all
Bellamy thought Clark was totally
privileged but as they began to share
leadership duties they started to
respect each other they learned to trust
each other and it turned into an awesome
friendship do you remember how awful it
was when Bellamy had to leave Clark on
earth but she survived and he was so
glad now they are both in cryo sleep
they will wake up in a new location and
start over they have been through a lot
together maybe they will finally realize
how perfect they are for each other it
will only take 130 years
teaching you would take days and you
knowing you you you probably still
screwed up Jasper and Maya there's
nothing like a tragic romance Jasper and
Maya will go down as one of these
saddest stories ever
they're basically Romeo and Juliet from
the future Maya was amazing she was such
a kind gentle character she really cared
about helping others and she was so
smart Maya was one of the mountain men
and worked in the medical section when
she first meets Jasper she instantly
feels something for him who can blame
her she even gives him her piece of
chocolate cake
they have such amazing chemistry and
bring out the best in each other
Jasper saves Maya's life then Maya shows
him the harvest chamber can you say
scary she doesn't want him to be next we
love all the scenes where they are
together that scene with the piano got
us right in the fields it was so sweet
it's obvious they care about each other
sadly Maya's exposed to too much
radiation and doesn't survive past
season two don't mind us we'll just
pretend that Maya and Jasper survived
and lived happily ever after together
that's what fanfic is for right Miller
and Jackson even though this is a cannon
ship we don't get to see too much of
Miller and Jackson as a couple Miller is
an interesting character we are so glad
he becomes a more important character as
the show goes on Miller is a fighter
he's super tough he's also very blunt
which we love Miller was originally
dating Brian they knew each other back
on the ark but Miller was thrown in jail
for stealing and later sent to earth
they were reunited in season three and
Miller was such a great boyfriend but
they broke up they disagreed about too
much we were kind of glad that they
broke up because that made a way for
Jackson Jackson is an awesome character
he's smart tough and a great leader he's
a good contrast to Miller when we found
out that they were dating at the
beginning of season five we were stoked
but we hardly get to see them together
at all they are both going to be in
season six we can't wait to see how
their relationship develops in this new
place if you aren't a much of a miller
and jackson shipper keep watching there
might be something else even better for
Miller Raven and Shaw will be first to
meet Shaw he doesn't seem like a good
match for Raven at all he is one of
Dioses followers at first but their
relationship turned out to be one
the best parts of season 5 Shahs a good
guy he's funny and kind of arrogant but
he tries to do what is right he betrays
day Yosa because he doesn't want to
launch the missiles he says that Raven
is the one who hacked the codes he loves
how smart she is
he helps Raven escape from diosa later
she helps him escape Raven is such a
tough character she's strong-willed and
she's never afraid to break the rules
she also has mad computer skills in fact
she and Shaw have similar skills she's
very independent and she needs a guy who
can deal with that Shaw is totally that
guy he respects her for her toughness
and intelligence at the end of season 5
Shaw is still asleep in the cryo chamber
he has no idea that 125 years have
passed instead of 10 will he and Raven
be able to overcome this crazy time jump
and a new life we sure hope so we want
to see a lot more of their relationship
in the new season Raven and Clarke Raven
and Clarke are the two characters with
the most romantic relationships and the
100 and they are very similar they are
both fierce AAF they aren't afraid to
break rules to get what they want or do
what needs to be done and they are both
really intelligence this non-canon ship
is one of the most popular these two
seem to be made for each other
plus it's obvious from the beginning of
the series that Clarke is totally into
Raven she gets upset when she finds out
that Raven and fen were dating but is
because she likes fen or was she
disappointed that Raven was taken they
overcome the whole Finn drama and become
friends later she tells Raven that she
would pick her that's not just something
you say to a friend these two alpha
females work together very well
they don't need Finn they take care of
each other and the chemistry is totally
there they would be such a power couple
we wonder what their relationship will
be like in season 6 Kane and Abby it's
not just the young characters that make
awesome couples
Abby is Clarke's mom she is one fierce
woman she speaks her mind and does what
she thinks is right she is the one who
convinces Marcus that just because
something is legal doesn't make it right
they disagree a lot but that just makes
them stronger
Abby totally falls for him Marcus is the
one who helps her get over her deceased
husband it's so romantic
Marcus even takes the
ship in season 3 just to save her ABI
and Marcus are both noble but they love
each other more than anything he
believes in her humanity when she has to
make terrible decisions in space Abby
gets a brain injury and she refuses
treatment she doesn't believe she is
worthy of survival because of the
decisions she has made she begs came to
let her die but he refuses he gasses her
and keeps her inside the bunker he
apologizes but he just couldn't bear to
be without her we think Abby would make
the same decision about Kane they see
the best in each other even when they
can't see it in themselves we hope that
their relationship can survive 125 years
of cryo sleep Monty and Miller there are
so many great ships in the 100 and there
are even more ships that we wish would
happen one of our favorite non-canon
ships is minty that's right Monty and
Miller somehow Miller ends up with
Jackson but they barely have any
interactions but Monty Miller are seen
together on lots and they have serious
chemistry these two men become close
friends when they try to escape Mount
weather Monty compliments Miller when he
is feeling down telling him he is a
great thief he actually succeeds in
making Miller laugh and who can forget
that card game scene you were digging
the bromance there are not a ton of
reasons to smile in the 100 life is
pretty grim but they always make each
other grin you can see it in season 3
when they are listening to Jasper's
music their friends should become
strained when their own opposite sighs
well at least Monty didn't bug Miller
like Brian did Monty would definitely be
a better boyfriend than Brian
we really missed their relationship as
the show went on and if they aren't your
OTP they are definitely our bro TP we
love these two guys
we're bums that we won't see any more
Monty in season six
who is your the 100 OTP let us know in
the comments thanks for watching click
that subscribe button for more awesome
videos from the things see you next time
[Music]